düsseldorf und dem präsidenten des
zentralrats der juden in deutschland
schuster mit dabei auch mal am stern vom
jüdischen weltkongress und der
innenminister sachsen anhalts
stahlknecht
wir schalten sofort zu dieser
pressekonferenz wir haben die leitung
nach halle auf liegen aber ich sehe noch
hat sie nicht begonnen
deshalb haben wir noch zeit um in eine
andere wichtige pressekonferenz rain zu
hören die der generalbundesanwalt frank
zusammen mit bundesjustizministerin
lamprecht vor einer halben stunde in
karlsruhe gegeben hat zum neuesten stand
der ermittlungen nach dem attentat in
halle
wir sind alle tief erschüttert über die
feigen über die feigen taten in halle
und unsere aktuellen gedanken sind bei
den opfern und ihren angehörigen
den angehörigen der bei dieser feigen in
farmen tat getöteten spreche ich mein
tief empfundenes beileid aus und den
verletzten wünsche ich alles gute
schnelle und vollständige genesung
er beauftragte der bundesregierung für
opfer von terroranschlägen dr edgar
franke steht allen angehörigen der opfer
der jüdischen gemeinde den angehörigen
der verletzten aber auch all denjenigen
die diese schreckliche tat miterleben
mussten als ansprechpartner zur
verfügung nach den aktuellen
erkenntnissen handelt es sich um einen
rechtsextremistischen terror anschlag
eines einzeltäters
wir gehen davon aus dass er aus
antisemitischen rechtsextremistischen
gründen handelte und die jüdische
gemeinde in der synagoge in halle zum
ziel hatte und nur durch glückliche
umstände wenn man das in dem
zusammenhang sagen kann ist es ihm nicht
gelungen in die synagoge einzudringen
wir müssen an der stelle ganz deutlich
machen dass wir unsere jüdischen
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger deutlich
besser schützen müssen
ihnen gilt unsere soll
qualität und es gehört zu unserer
staatsräson dass juden in deutschland
sicher leben können
wir alle sind gefordert antisemitismus
in jeder form im alltag konsequent
entgegenzutreten
wir müssen feststellen
nicht erst seit dem mord am kasseler
regierungspräsidenten dr walter lübke
dass rechtsextremismus hierzulande
gewalttätiger aggressiver auftritt
und deswegen ist das eine immer größer
werdende ich finde eine der größten
bedrohungen der wir uns aktuell
gegenüber sehen und deswegen müssen wir
mit allen mitteln die wir als
rechtsstaat zur verfügung haben
dieser bedrohung entgegen wirken wir
alle sind aufgefordert
verantwortungsbewusst zu handeln
wir müssen uns aber auch den nährboden
anschauen auf dem diese
rechtsextremistische gewalt wächst und
dieser nährboden ist oftmals ein
nährboden der zuerst beginnt mit worten
und diesen worten folgen dann taten und
insbesondere im internet erleben wir
eine zunehmende verrohung hass und hetze
nehmen zu
und deswegen bin ich nicht länger
bereits dieses zu akzeptieren ich werde
vorschläge vorlegen wie wir
netzwerkbetreiber stärker in die
verantwortung nehmen wenn morddrohungen
und volksverhetzung 'nen ausgesprochen
werden im internet dann brauchen wir
eine pflicht dass diese an die
ermittlungsbehörden weitergeleitet
werden damit diese konsequent verfolgen
können
wir sind alle aufgefordert konsequent zu
handeln
diese demokratie dieser rechtsstaat ist
es wert konsequent für ein einzustehen
das war die bundesjustizministerin und
nach justizministerin lambrecht hat sich
der generalbundesanwalt geäußert da
hören wir auch schnell rein was wir
gestern erlebt haben war terror nach
unseren
erkenntnissen hat der beschuldigte
stephan b gestern sich zum ziel gesetzt
in der jüdischen gemeinde zu halle in
der synagoge von halle an der saale ein
massaker anzurichten stefan b ein mensch
der wohl tief durchdrungen von einem
erschreckenden antisemitismus
fremdenhass rassismus geprägt war hatte
sich schwer bewaffnet mit mehreren
waffen augenscheinlich selbst gebaut mit
einer großen menge von sprengstoff
allein im pkw wurden etwa vier kilogramm
sprengstoff in der gesamtmenge
festgestellt in zahlreichen
sprengvorrichtungen er wollte dorthin
gehen in die synagoge und dort
zahlreiche menschen zu töten
er sah sich in einer tradition
vergleichbare attentäter vergleichbar
ähnlich wie bränden tarrant den
attentäter von christchurch
stefan b wollte nach unserer erkenntnis
und einschätzung eine weltweite wirkung
erzeugen durch das live gefilmte
tatgeschehen durch seine kommentare
während des tatgeschehens durch sein
manifest uns seinen plan den er vorher
im internet verbreitet und hochgeladen
hat stefan b wollte nach unserer
einschätzung ein nachahmer im doppelten
sinne sein
er wollte nachahmen vergleichbare taten
die vorher begangen wurden und er wollte
nach unserer erkenntnis auch andere zu
solchen taten zur nachahmung an stiften
oder sie veranlassen
wir werfen stefan b das tatgeschehen
kennen sie alle
wir werfen stefan bevor zweifacher mord
versuchter mord in neuen fällen und
andere straftaten
wir haben haftbefehl beantragt beim
ermittlungsrichter des
bundesgerichtshofs stephan b wird noch
heute dem ermittlungsrichter des
bundesgerichtshofs hier in karlsruhe
vorgeführt
wir haben die wohnung des beschuldigten
durchsuchen lassen
derzeit werden die dabei
sichergestellten asservate genauso wie
diese waffen wie diese sprengmittel
kriminaltechnisch untersucht und stellen
sich viele fragen viele fragen wie
konnte es kommen dass so ein mensch sich
radikalisiert wie konnte es kommen dass
sich stephan b zudem entschließen konnte
was er gestern getan hat wie hat er sich
waffen beschaffen können waffen selber
bauen können sprengmittel selber bauen
können wie ist er an all diese
grundstoffe herangekommen gab es
eventuell unterstützer gab es eventuell
mitwisser gab es andere vielleicht auch
nur über das netz die mit ihm vorher in
kontakt getreten waren personen die ihn
vielleicht animiert angestachelt oder
ähnliches haben
dem werden wir nachgehen dazu ist es
erforderlich
seine gesamte kommunikation zu
durchleuchten
dazu ist es auch erforderlich zu schauen
welche aktivitäten hat er im darknet vor
vorab durchgeführt diese ermittlungen
werden
eine gewisse zeit sich hinziehen wir
haben auf diese fragen heute noch keine
klaren antworten deswegen bitte ich um
verständnis dass ich auch aus
ermittlungstaktischen gründen keine
weiteren einzelheiten bekannt geben kann
und auch auf einiges auf einige fragen
die sich uns stellen auch heute noch gar
keine klare antwort habe soweit der
generalbundesanwalt in karlsruhe sie
haben es selbst gesehen die
pressekonferenz in halle hat noch nicht
begonnen da warten wir weiter und
schalten sofort dahin wenn wir
bundesinnenminister seehofer dort sehen
deshalb
in der zwischenzeit einfach nochmal nach
karlsruhe zurück denn sarah attacke hat
dort die pressekonferenz des
generalbundesanwalts verfolgt sarah das
war ja nun ein relativ kurzes statement
von ihm sind denn das viele neue
erkenntnisse gewesen wie schätzen sie
das ein
sie haben es gehört es wurden hier viele
fragen gestellt das liegt daran dass der
täter seine tat ja live gestreamt hat
das heißt es ist komplett dokumentiert
jetzt seinen plan vor dem internet
veröffentlicht er hat ein manifest
veröffentlicht das heißt was ihn bewegt
was ihn motiviert hat wie er die tat
begangen hat
all das ist bereits dokumentiert
öffentlich und bekannt und deswegen gab
es wenig neue details entscheidend ist
natürlich und das ist das was der
generalbundesanwalt hier an fragen
formuliert hat entscheidend ist hatte er
kontakte in die rechte szene war er vom
dem verfassungsschutz irgendwann mal
bekannt hatte er unterstützer im
internet oder in der echten welt
und wie konnte er sich überhaupt
radikalisieren wie konnte er sich
unbemerkt radikalisieren all das sind
die zentralen fragen und hier wurde
heute gesagt darauf haben wir leider
noch überhaupt gar keine antworten das
fragen sich die ermittler selber sie
haben die wohnung durchsucht und
erhoffen sich nun dass sie durch das
auswerten von datenträger der neue
erkenntnisse bekommen also im moment
noch mehr fragen als antworten
was zeigt das ganze aber dass die
bundesanwaltschaft das verfahren an sich
gezogen hat auch das hat der
generalbundesanwalt heute im grunde ganz
deutlich gemacht der generalbundesanwalt
ist der staatsanwalt des bundes er wird
immer tätig wenn es um staatsgefährdende
straftaten geht wenn der wir menschen in
deutschland insgesamt in gefahr sind
wenn es politisch motivierte taten sind
wenn es um terror geht und hier das war
heute ja sein erster satz
hier geht's um terror hier geht's um
krassesten antisemitismus hier geht es
um rechtsradikalismus und da war ganz
schnell klar
der generalbundesanwalt wird ermitteln
der generalbundesanwalt
anklagen und wird sich um diese
ermittlung kümmern er hat auch gesagt
dass er sehr früh eingebunden worden die
staatsanwaltschaft vor ort hat sehr früh
gesagt das ist hier eine ganz besondere
eine besonders krasse eine besonders
schlimme eine staatsgefährdende straftat
und deshalb ist der generalbundesanwalt
hier bei den ermittlungen beteiligt und
für sie sie sagen dass selbst ist zeigt
die bedeutung dieses falls die
bundesanwaltschaft hat ja angekündigt im
laufe des tages beim ermittlungsrichter
einen haftbefehl zu beantragen was
wissen sie dazu genau der haftbefehl ist
beantragt und der täter sollen noch
heute dem ermittlungsrichter vorgeführt
werden
er ist leicht verletzt allerdings noch
transportfähig das wurde mir hier gesagt
und deshalb wird es heute noch diese
vorführung geben noch eine frage zur
konstellation so zu sagen wir haben
immer wieder statements eines
generalbundesanwalts das ist klar aber
jetzt war die bundesjustizministerin an
seiner seite beide haben diese
pressekonferenz zusammen gegeben was
bedeutet das es ist wahrscheinlich weil
die bundesjustizministerin heute sowieso
in karlsruhe war dass sie hier heute
gesagt hat lassen sie uns das statement
gemeinsam machen aber es ist natürlich
auch der besonderheit der tat geschuldet
sie haben ihre worte gehört ihr war es
heute sicher ein anliegen noch mal
deutlich zu machen dass wir in
deutschland ganz entschieden
antisemitismus entgegentreten dass es
eine staatsraison ist dass wir hier
geschlossen auftreten müssen und deshalb
weil es ihr wichtig hier heute auch noch
mal zu sprechen und das ganz ganz
deutlich zu machen sei attacke vielen
dank für die informationen und die
einschätzung vielen dank nach karlsruhe
ja wir haben weiterhin halle im blick
die pressekonferenz mit
bundesinnenminister seehofer hat noch
nicht begonnen das sehen wir die
bundeskanzlerin hat bereits gestern
abend ihre solidarität gezeigt in berlin
in dem sie spontan an einer
veranstaltung vor der synagoge
oranienburger straße teilgenommen hat
vor etwa einer stunde äußerte sich
merkel erneut über den anschlag beim
gewerkschaftstag der ig metall
in nürnberg ich bin die millionen
menschen in deutschland schockiert und
bedrückt von dem verbrechen das gestern
in halle verübt worden ist
[Applaus]
ich trauere mit den familien und
freunden der ermordeten in diesen
stunden die so schmerzlich sind
ich denke an die verletzten und wir alle
wissen wir sind nur sehr knapp einem
schrecklichen angriff auf die menschen
in der synagoge entgangen und es hätte
noch sehr viel mehr opfer geben können
und ich sage habe es gestern in berlin
an der neunzehn google gesagt und ich
wiederhole es hier
wir sind froh über jede synagoge über
jede jüdische gemeinde und überall
jüdisches leben in unserem land und das
heißt zuallererst und als das stehe ich
ja hier auch vor ihnen dass die
repräsentanten des rechtsstaates alle
mittel des rechtsstaates nutzen müssen
um gegen hass gewalt und
menschenfeindlichkeit vorzugehen
da gibt es keinerlei toleranz soweit
sich die kanzlerin vor etwa einer stunde
in nürnberg die pressekonferenz auf die
wir warten in halle hat noch nicht
begonnen sie verzögert sich noch ein
bisschen sie war für 15 uhr angekündigt
nutzen wir die zeit aber noch einmal und
blicken wir auf den tag den heutigen tag
tag eins nach dem attentat noch immer
ist die stadthalle ist das ganze landen
fassungslos was der schwer bewaffnete
täter offenbar geplant hatte ein blutbad
in einer vollbesetzten jüdischen
synagoge viel glück verhinderte dies und
doch verloren zwei menschen ihr leben
bundespräsident steinmeier und sachsen
anhalts ministerpräsident haseloff waren
am mittag am tatort und gedachten der
opfer
halle an der saale kurz nach 12 uhr
mittags präsident steinmeier kommt zur
synagoge auf die gestern ein anschlag
verübt wurde eine schweigeminute für die
opfer
nachdem steinmeier sich mit vertretern
der gemeinde getroffen hat tritt er vor
die presse spricht zu einem tag der
scham und der shuttle gestern sind zwei
menschen gestorben
[Musik]
ermordet von einem täter der
offensichtlich zu allem bereit war zwei
weitere sind verletzt worden
unsere gedanken unseren mitgefühl sind
bei den angehörigen
die geschichte mahnt uns die gegenwart
fordert uns wir müssen haltung zeigen
über den mutmaßlichen täter ist derzeit
bekannt dass er zwei antisemitische
rechtsradikale manifeste veröffentlichte
seine waffen teilweise selbst nach
anleitungen aus dem internet bastelte
hier in bendorf bei halle durchsucht die
polizei in seiner wohnung
beschlagnahmten datenträger heiß
debattiert immer noch die tatsache dass
keine polizei vor der synagoge stand
gerade am höchsten jüdischen feiertag
jom kippur also es gibt ständige
kontakte zur polizei oder sind wirklich
inständig und kontakt aber nach
auffassung von polizei es war
ausreichend das die sporadisch ich weiß
nicht wie ich wie oft vom ball gefahren
sind
das habe ich nie sagen wir geprüft ob
diese da sind die haben gesagt wenn man
polizistin lädt das heißt nicht dass
polizei nicht da ist
bisher ist nur ein verdächtiger in haft
ob er aber ein einzeltäter ist steht
noch nicht fest
während er sie zu schnell jetzt zu sagen
das war mit sicherheit ein einzeltäter
das sollte man mich kann man auch nicht
sagen an dieser stelle
zu diesem zeitpunkt am frühen nachmittag
kam dann auch bundesinnenminister horst
seehofer nach halle um sich vor ort über
die bluttat und ihre folgen zu
informieren verständlich wir wollen mehr
wissen über den täter wer er ist hatte
er komplizen was waren seine motive aber
wir wollen auch blicken auf die die
zielscheibe seines angriffs waren
anfeindungen gegen juden und jüdische
einrichtungen
wir haben in jüngster vergangenheit
deutlich zugenommen der anschlag kam
also nicht aus dem nichts schon vor dem
gestrigen tag gab es unter juden in
deutschland das begründete bedürfnis
nach sicherheit und schutz
jetzt ist die angst nur noch größer
geworden diese tür hielt der gewalt den
schüssen des attentäter stand ein
massaker in der synagoge wurde
verhindert knapp 60 menschen beteten zur
tatzeit darin und verfolgten das
geschehen von innen per
überwachungskamera mann hatte versucht
die türen zu stoßen es klappte nicht
und nachdem wir gehört jetzt zu ende es
ist ein bisschen zäh wir haben müssen
aufgaben
wir gucken weiter auf die kamera also
gespannt wie befolgten wirklich live wie
praktisch unser tod auf uns zukommt und
nach und jetzt der weg aber ging nicht
mehr geht nochmal zum auto holte sachen
rausschmiss herüber ich sage druck durch
glücklich weil wir haben große fenster
in der synagoge und ich dachte wir
kommen jetzt einen knall
es kann keinen knall und dann
weggefahren jetzt läuft die debatte
warum weil die synagoge ausgerechnet an
ihrem gipfel nicht bewacht warum hatte
der täter so viel zeit wo war die
polizei die verteidigt sich es fehle an
personal
dieser fall zeigt uns wir dürfen die
polizei decke ist da hält niemand sich
zurück und sagt nun warten wir erstmal
prozent vor ort weiter ergibt sondern da
wird sofort alles in die gänge gesetzt
aber es war höchstwahrscheinlich nicht
schneller möglich
gestern abend die kanzlerin und viele
andere menschen vor der neuen synagoge
in berlin
solidarität und entsetzen das aber
reiche nicht sagen manche schon länger
fühlten sich juden nicht mehr sicher in
deutschland im alltag eine erfahrung
habe eingesetzt
viele menschen der jüdischen
gemeinschaft fühlen sich verängstigt zu
recht wie ich finde
eben jede woche irgendwelche meldungen
dass juden auf der straße angepöbelt
werden weil sie eine kippa tragen oder
weil sie mit einem davidstern eben
identifiziert werden als juden das ist
die forderung neben der nach der
aufarbeitung möglicher polizeilicher
fehler jetzt nicht zur tagesordnung
zurückzukehren
wir warten weiteren auch die
pressekonferenz in halle mit dabei ja
auch der präsident des zentralrats der
juden in deutschland schuster und mariam
stern vom jüdischen weltkongress die
pressekonferenz verschiebt sich aber
noch wir schalten sofort hin wenn wir
sehen dass sie beginnt wir nutzen die
zeit anfang und sprechen mit felix
zimmermann aus unserer redaktion recht
und justiz der attentäter hat seine tat
ja mit einer helmkamera gefilmt das
video wollen wir natürlich nicht zeigen
werde natürlich nicht einem attentäter
noch eine bühne geben wollen
felix du hast ja aber das video
angeschaut und welche erkenntnisse
können denn die ermittler aus diesem
video gewinnen
ja wir haben ja gehört die ermittler
sind schon recht weit mit ihrem
vermutung und das liegt daran dass der
täter auf diesem video eben was
preisgegeben hat er sagt am anfang
es habe den holocaust nicht gegeben
schimpft dann über feminismus und
masseneinwanderung und macht für alle
probleme die juden verantwortlich und
hat das zeigt natürlich da ist er eine
rechtsextreme gesinnung hat das hier
sich die verdacht von gestern bestätigt
dass es eben sich im treppenhaus und
antisemitismus handelt muss allerdings
auch sagen so eine tat wie er derart im
party los dort die menschen tötet ob da
nicht auch eine psychische störung
vorliegt das müssen jetzt weitere
untersuchungen zeigen
jetzt gibt es neben dem video aber noch
ein dokument des attentäters das verrät
auch so einiges worum handelt es sich da
ja uns liegt ein pdf vor ein
schriftliches dokument und
sicherheitsbehörden bestätigen auch dass
das echt ist und dort erzählt führt der
täter eben seine ziele auf warum er
diese schreckliche tat macht und die
ziele sind die folgen und erst mal
möchte er so viel wie möglich an die
weiße töten vor allem juden dann möchte
er mit der veröffentlichung des videos
angeblich weißen unterdrückte moral zu
münchen und schließlich geht es ihm
darum die brauchbarkeit von
selbstgebauten waffen zu belegen und das
ist ja wirklich ganz erschreckende
dimensionen hier die dokumente die uns
vorliegen und auch die sicherheitskreise
sagen dass das der verdacht naheliegt
dass er mit einem 3d drucker elemente
von diesem wasser neben ausgedruckt hat
und dass er quasi dies benutzt habe um
diese dieses massaker dann anzurichten
und das natürlich eine ganz neue
dimension dass sich jemand plötzlich
wachsen ausdrucken kann oder einen
terroristischen anschlag begehen kann
nun hat er habe ich gelesen du hast es
ja schon gesagt in dem video gibt ja
auch etwas über sich preis und er hat
sich da einen annon genannt was bedeutet
das was ist der hintergrund ja das ist
auch in ändern das ist in der sprache in
der sich der bewegt diesen es gibt einen
forum das heißt fortune und dieses forum
dann nennen sich alle das heißt nms das
heißt jeglicher eintrag in diesem forum
also alles anonym
genau jeglicher eintrag in diesen foren
jetzt überhaupt nicht auf eine bestimmte
person bezogen und alle heißen ändern
ja und diese gesamte kommunikation
findet also in dieser art anonymen statt
und man muss schon sagen also natürlich
ist das hier rechts extremismus
terrorismus keine frage aber es ist
schon eine besondere art denn auf diesen
foren geht es darum sich gegenseitig
anzustarren es werden punkte vergeben
dafür für die schlimmsten attentate
scoring punkte also alles wie in einem
computerspiel und das ist natürlich noch
mal alle dimensionen dass er genau
diesen weg gehen wollte zeigen auch
dieses manifest das dokument denn dort
hat er in perfider weise wie das bei
einer spielfigur der fall ist beim
computerspiel sah mit manja trophäen
wenn man irgendwelche besonderen punkte
oder gegenstände einsammeln und dass er
daher auf perfide weise gemacht nämlich
bestimmte ziele gesetzt hat solche
menschen und bringen solche menschen
einen christen umbringen und dann wie
eine art trophäe die er sich dann
sammeln wollte alles zeigt schon dass
der psychopathische züge alles andere
als ausgeschlossen sind
jetzt erinnert das ja auch ein bisschen
an das attentat in christchurch da hat
ein attentäter versucht muslime
umzubringen hat das ganze aber auch
versucht zu
die tat gibt es da parallelen hat er
sich dazu geäußert genau das ist genau
die parallele weil da war das nämlich
auch alles auf einem forum da hieß es
age an also und da hat der attentäter
von kreisstadt dort alles live gepostet
und das war ihm ganz ähnlich und hat
sich da auch feiern lassen muss jetzt
mal sehen wir könnten mal reinschauen
und dieses tag netz von diesen foren
sind wie jetzt das besprochen wird
das wird doch nicht etwa gesprochen wie
konnte er so etwas tun sondern was ein
looser hat der total schlecht
abgeschnitten
er hat keinen guten score ist ja so wird
das da rezitiert und wenn wir jetzt mal
schauen dass die bundesjustizministerin
sagt ich möchte gegen hass im netz
vorgehen ist es noch mal eine ganz
andere kategorie in diesem netz völlig
anonym
als wir es jetzt irgendwie bei facebook
zu tun haben wo wir ein prinzipiell
rechtstreuen portalbetreiber haben hier
ist eine regulierung quasi
ausgeschlossen
und wir haben ja noch nicht mal eine
zurechnung weil ich eben alle an
anonymous nennt also besteht hier auch
an ermittlungsgründen und im hinblick
auf die gefahrenabwehr von der riesigen
herausforderung so was in zukunft zu
verhindern
vielen dank für die informationen die
einschätzung die einordnungen felix
zimmermann vielen dank wir warten
weiterhin auf die pressekonferenz in der
polizeiinspektion in halle dort wird
eben unter anderem bundesinnenminister
seehofer erwartet diese pressekonferenz
ist ja außergewöhnlich besetzt noch mit
vielen anderen hochkarätigen sprechern
annegret oster ist in halle vor dem ort
wissen sie warum die pk sich die
pressekonferenz der zeitverzögert sie
war er für 15 uhr angesetzt ja das
stimmt die pressekonferenz war für 15
uhr angesetzt kurz vor 15 uhr kam ein
polizeisprecher und sagt 'das würde sich
mindestens um 15 minuten verzögern das
ganze ich denke dass die teilnehmer
unterwegs sind hintergrund gespräche
führen darüber gibt es keine
offiziellen auskünfte es ist hier
bewegung aber ich sehe noch keine es
kann jede minute los gehen wann genau
darüber gibt es keine auskünfte
der innenminister des landes sachsen
anhalt kommt gerade rein
das heißt es sieht so aus als ob es
jetzt bald losgehen wird ich guck mal
richtung eingang noch sind keine
weiteren politiker zu sehen sie haben
schon gesagt carsten sehr hochrangig
besetzt bundes da kommt herr seehofer
der bundesinnenminister
ja wir können davon ausgehen dass es
jetzt gleich losgeht an den kritikern
ganz kurz noch während der see vor auf
dem weg ist wir erhalten sofort hin wenn
er ans mikrofon tritt aber wahr am stern
vom jüdischen weltkongress ist auch
dabei ist angereist wie kann man denn
das einschätzen dass die hohe bedeutung
dass nicht nur halle nicht nur
deutschland auf diese pressekonferenz
blickt sondern eigentlich die ganze welt
ja also neben dem zentralrat der juden
gibt ihr präsident schuster ist eben
auch mal am stern vom jüdischen
weltverband angereist das zeigt die
extraordinäre internationale bedeutung
dieses anschlages
man muss wissen der jüdische
weltkongress kongress ist dafür da die
politischen belange aller juden die
außerhalb von israel leben zu vertreten
und die anwesenheit von marc am stern
zeigt wie gesagt diese außerordentliche
bedeutung dieses anschlags oder dieses
anschlagsversuche
dann sind wir gespannt was wir dort
hören werden auch herr schuster ist da
er hat sich ja schon geäußert
als präsident des zentralrats der juden
in deutschland er hat ja auch kritik
geäußert warum die polizei diese
synagoge in halle nicht geschützt hat
hat er sich heute im laufe des tages
auch noch mal dazu geäußert oder dürfen
wir vielleicht jetzt noch einiges
erwarten
also ich denke wird sich dazu in jedem
fall noch einmal äußern er hat vorbei
der bei einer kranzniederlegung vor der
synagoge sich dazu noch mal geäußert die
medien gegenüber und hat das noch mal
wiederholt gesagt generell kann es nicht
sein dass gerade an einem so hoch
stehenden jüdischen feiertag jom kippur
eine synagoge nicht besetzt ist und
fordert massive nachbesserungen der
polizei wir haben auch von anwohnern
gehört dass generell die synagoge nicht
bewacht gewesen sei und dass polizei so
gut wie niemals dort zu sehen gewesen
sei das wird also durchaus interessant
sein man muss ja sagen der innenminister
des landes sachsen anhalt wird sozusagen
nebenher im stern sitzen und insofern
wird das schon sicherlich ganz spannend
sie haben ja aber auch gesprochen mit
dem vorsitzenden der jüdischen gemeinde
in halle
wie hat er sich denn geäußert ja erst
mal hat er sich entsetzt und schockiert
gezeigt er war ja wirklich live dabei er
war in der synagoge zusammen mit 60 70
gläubigen die eben diesen höchsten
jüdischen feiertag begangen haben
und er hat miterlebt hat die bilder über
der von der überwachungskamera gesehen
wie dieser attentäter versucht hat sich
den weg frei zu schießen hat auf die tür
der synagoge geschossen
daraufhin hat wohl der der rabbi ganz
schnell reagiert so erzählt er hat die
gemeinde gebeten sich einen anderen raum
zurückzuziehen
sie haben dann von innen die tür
verriegelt und man kann sagen es ist ein
riesiges glück davon spricht der
vorsitzende jüdischen gemeinde auch hat
gesagt es ist fast ein wunder dass diese
tür gehalten hat und tatsächlich ein
blutbad ein massaker verhindert werden
konnte annegret oster vielen vielen dank
für diese informationen und wir schauen
jetzt in den saal sozusagen hinter ihnen
denn da müsste jetzt in wenigen sekunden
tatsächlich die pressekonferenz beginnen
da sehen wir auch schon
bundesinnenminister seehofer den
ministerpräsidenten des landes sachsen
anhalt und was sie sagen da hören wir
jetzt sein
wir sind verschwunden
also sie sehen jetzt hier anscheinend
steht noch nicht fest wer wohl als
erstes sprechen soll sie sehen aber
links innenminister bundesinnenminister
seehofer neben ihm im gespräch den
ministerpräsidenten des landes
sachsen-anhalt haseloff rechts daneben
holger stahlknecht er ist der
innenminister von sachsen anhalt damit
auch zuständig verantwortlich für die
polizei in sachsen anhalt und wir haben
es geben mit unserer reporterin annegret
oster besprochen eigentlich ist es schon
sehr interessant dass eben auch der
präsident des zentralrats der juden in
deutschland josef schuster mit dabei
sein soll
denn er deutliche kritik geübt an der
polizei dass sie ausgerechnet an dem
höchsten feiertag der juden am gestrigen
tag nicht präsent war vor der synagoge
die synagoge nicht geschützt hat und
insofern können wir gespannt sein wie
diese pressekonferenz verlaufen wird
welche erkenntnisse einerseits es gibt
vom bundesinnenminister vom
innenminister des landes sachsen anhalt
aber auch eventuelle welche kritik geübt
wird von jüdischer seite vom zentralrat
der juden und wie vielleicht auch der
innenminister und für die polizei
verantwortliche minister stark nicht
darauf reagieren wird so sie sehen es
selber da herrscht noch ein bisschen
uneinigkeit vielleicht wer beginnt und
die mikrofone an sind aber wie gesagt
sobald die herren sich äußern werden
schalten wir hin sie verpassen nichts
es ist ein volles programm
bundespräsident steinmeier war zunächst
heute morgen an der synagoge an dem
tatort danach ist bundesinnenminister
seehofer auch dort gewesen
beide wurden begleitet vom
ministerpräsidenten sachsen-anhalts
haseloff und insofern haben die beiden
sicherlich seehofer und haseloff schon
gespräche geführt annegret oster hat es
eben gesagt vielleicht liegt s
die die verschiebung die verzögerung
auch daran dass man sich auch noch mal
absprechen wollte musste was man sagt
wie man mit dem fall umgeht und das
ganze einschätzt die tatsache dass der
bundesinnenminister
das mikrofon näher heranrückt lässt uns
dann vermuten dass vielleicht eher
anfangen wird sie sehen links neben
herrn seehofer neben dem
bundesinnenminister sitzt jetzt der
präsident des zentralrats der juden in
deutschland josef schuster von annegret
oster bereits angesprochen wie gesagt es
wird interessant sein wie auch er sich
äußern wird er der präsident des
zentralrats der juden der gestern wie
gesagt bereits kritik geäußert hat neben
der betroffenheit
viele damen und herren wir hatten heute
den bundespräsidenten hier und halle und
sachsen anhalt zu gast haben jetzt den
bundesinnenminister
wir haben gestern einen furchtbaren tag
gehabt und ich kann ihnen sagen das
gesamte land und auch die stadthalle
oberbürgermeister ist ja auch hier
anwesend wir leiden unter dem was wir
gestern erlebt haben und wir sind immer
noch tief betroffen und voller schmerzen
was den verlust zweier menschen leben
angelangt ich gerade auch nach zwei
verletzte im krankenhaus besuchen und
all das was sich in der jüdischen
gemeinde in der synagoge dort ereignet
hat das ist auch für uns in der
rekapitulation des bisher vorliegenden
so furchtbar dass sie davon ausgehen
können dass wir noch sehr sehr lange
auch mental damit versuchen müssen
umzugehen aber eben auch gar nicht klar
entsprechende maßnahmen besprochen haben
und noch einleiten werden will die sich
aus den ereignissen ergeben dass er wird
gleich der innenminister noch die bisher
vorliegenden erkenntnisse fachlich
vortragen im rahmen seiner zuständigkeit
ich möchte nur eine politische grundsatz
bewertung wird das land noch mal
vornehmen
das land sachsen-anhalt ist ein land was
weltoffen ist und was von pluralität und
respekt vor der menschenwürde und auch
vor allen dingen der religionsfreiheit
getragen ist religionsfreiheit als hohes
gut
und dazu gehört auch dass sich
diejenigen die sich als bürger nahmen
bürger auch zum beispiel in der
jüdischen gemeinde hier und halle aber
auch sonst in sachsen-anhalt
entsprechend auch organisiert haben
sicher sein müssen dass sie ihren
glauben und ihre religion ausüben können
und dass sie auch jetzt sagen als
bestandteil unserer gesellschaft als
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger auch davon
ausgehen können dass alle
sicherheitsmaßnahmen die möglich sind
werden damit auch das auch für die
zukunft war gestellt werden kann und wir
haben gestern nacht noch gestern abend
noch in der nacht noch mit dem leiter
der jüdischen gemeinde hier lange
darüber geredet was die konsequenz aus
dem furchtbaren geschehnisse gestern ist
und ich möchte das wie folgt
zusammenfassen erster diese gesellschaft
lässt sich nicht auseinanderbringen
wir werden zusammenhalten wir werden das
auch heute zeigen um 17 uhr mit der
stadt gemeinsam in vielen
gesellschaftlichen kräften auf dem
marktplatz auch morgen bei der präsenz
um mal mit feiern der des gottesdienstes
anlässlich des sabbat in der jüdischen
gemeinde her
wir haben am montag um 18 uhr ebenfalls
ein ökumenischer gottesdienst in der
marktkirche abhalten und alles was
soziale sicherheitstechnisch zu machen
ist wird auch der minister aus ich bin
dankbar dass sowohl der bundespräsident
als auch der bundesinnenminister
horst seehofer ist eher sache mit
unterstützen und auch projekt das
anwesen seien auch dokumentieren dass
wir hier als deutschland insgesamt noch
verantwortung spielen das ist ja nicht
nur mit einem singulären ereignis
gestern zu tun haben sondern dass wir
und dafür steht auch herr schuster hier
mit ganz klar in der reihe der ihnen die
auch noch das wort nehmen werden dass
wir für alle jüdischen bürgerinnen
bürger und gemeinden in deutschland
dafür sorgen müssen dass bestimmte
sachen ausgeschlossen werden nicht
stattfinden beziehungsweise auch alle
maßnahmen die dafür erforderlich sind
auch ergriffen werden und dazu haben wir
auch eine ganze reihe von fachgesprächen
tage auch geführt auch mit den
betroffenen
für mich ist folgendes ganz ganz wichtig
die mitglieder der gemeinde in der
gemeinden in sachsen-anhalt wir werden
das morgen auch mit entsprechenden
lichterketten entlang
im kreise der entsprechenden synagogen
in sachsen-anhalt dokumentieren als
bürgerinnen und bürger diese müssten
sich so sicher fühlen dass sie nicht
davon abgehalten werden durch die
ereignisse von gestern in ihren
gottesdiensten feiern noch nicht wo
schon verpflichtung nachzukommen
das ist so ein hohes gut dass wir auch
damit zeigen wollen jüdisches leben ist
nicht nur erwünscht
wir wissen welche schlimm einschnitten
durch den holocaust hatten welche
geschichtliche verantwortung wir haben
in deutschland und auch in
sachsen-anhalt welche bühnen gemeinden
wir früher hatten und dass wir jetzt
wieder kleine gemeinden die wachsen
können auch wieder und sachsen anhalt
haben und wir auch in den nächsten
jahren zwei neue synagoge bauen wollen
nämlich investor und den magdeburg mit
all den dingen die wir
sicherheitstechnisch dafür zur verfügung
stellen müssen
darüber haben wir heute auch gesprochen
und letzte bemerkung auch dazu ich habe
heute auch den antrag an die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die in 14
tagen in bayern stattfinden wird
gestellt dass wir dieses thema
einheitliche standards einheitliche
verfahrensweisen einheitliche
sicherheits maßnahmen auch mit den
anderen ministerpräsidenten für
deutschland insgesamt auch diskutieren
wollen und dass wir dazu auch einen
entsprechenden einstieg thematisch bis
in die rechtliche prüfung hinein
vornehmen müssen dass wir an die dinge
heran kommen die unabhängig davon ob für
ein einzeltier dort unterwegs war oder
nicht dass wir sicherstellen dass wir
den sumpf der sich hier ergibt im sinne
von rechtsradikalismus und 12.000
bekannten gewaltbereiten rechtsradikalen
in deutschland so begegnen können dass
wir als demokraten sicher sein können
dass diese nicht und so folglich
demokratische grundordnung die würde des
einzelnen menschen der einzelnen person
in frage stellen das können wir nicht
zulassen da müssen wir handeln da müssen
wir auch unseren rechtsrahmen
weiterentwickeln
wir müssen ihnen sicherlich die existenz
ausschöpfen aber wir wissen dass wir
auch noch lücken schließen müssen und
das ist denke ich mal auch eine sache
die wir mit dem bund gemeinsam machen
sollten und auch wehren weil wir
ansonsten nicht weiter kommen damit
spreche ich auch die themenfelder an
das ereignet sich im dunklen netze im
dot net wie ist es möglich dass man sich
dort komponenten beschaffen kann um sie
aber waffen zusammenzubauen und mit
diesen waffen menschenleben tötet und
letztendlich auslöscht das sind alles
dinge für uns die wir nicht hinnehmen
wir sind und wo wir auch so lange nicht
ruhen werden bis wir hier auch weiter
kommen und auch den bürgerinnen bürgern
die sich jetzt auch gerade betroffen
gefühlt müssen nach dem dramatischen
ereignis in gestern auch in der synagoge
dass diese menschen entsprechend auch
zukünftig das vertrauen in unseren
rechtsstaat in auch in deutschland
insgesamt hinein nicht verlieren oder in
frage stellen sondern dass sie mit uns
gemeinsam glücklich ihr leben und ich
habe dort mit jungen menschen die hier
studieren in halle und auch zur gemeinde
gehirn gesprochen die sich bisher auch
mal sehr sehr wohl gefühlt haben und
dieses gefühl wollen wir auch weiterhin
aufrechterhalten und da lassen wir uns
von den dramatischen ereignissen von
gestern nicht aus dem tritt bringen
sondern werden dafür kämpfen dass das
auch weiterhin zukunft jeder preis
ändert meine wir haben herrn im vor zur
ergänzung zu dem was der herr
ministerpräsident gesagt hat das was
gestern passiert ist macht traurig
betroffen und wütend und wir erleben
hier in unserem bundesland 2016 im
parlament politische auseinandersetzung
die im duktus und fiktion an längst
vergessene zeiten erinnern lassen
ich hätte mir nicht vorstellen können
dass ms sprachgebrauch wiedereinzug im
parlament erhält
und ich hätte mir nicht vorstellen
können dass es wieder mord und totschlag
gegenüber andersdenkenden gibt an dass
glaubenden gibt und gegenüber
repräsentanten unseres staates
und diejenigen die sich dieser sprache
bedienen liegt nicht im juristischen
sinne der walze schuldig aber sie sind
die wegbereiter des etwas passiert sie
sind die geistigen brandstifter in
unserer bundesrepublik und aufgrund der
historischen verantwortung die wir in
deutschland haben als
alleinstellungsmerkmal dieses
gesellschaftlich so zusammen zu rücken
dass diese geistigen brandstifter keine
weiteren nährboden in deutschland finden
und dass solche taten sich nicht
wiederholen und dass wir alles tun um
mit der härte des staates dem zu
begegnen
zum tatablauf gestern um 12 uhr drei
ging in der rettungsleitstelle ein
notruf über 112 ein und zwar durch bevor
sitzen nicht wieder schön gemeinde der
heute mit uns auf dem podium sitzt wo er
geschildert dass es draußen zu
schießereien kommt das kann man auch
nach höheren in diesem beruf die
aufgezeichnet werden um 12 uhr vier ging
dann die meldung die ja bei der
rettungsleitstelle eingegangen war
hierbei der polizeiinspektion halle wo
wir uns befinden ein mit der mitteilung
über den anruf dass in der nähe der
synagoge auf dem jüdischen friedhof der
stadthalle eine person infolge einer
schuss anwendung tödlich verletzt worden
sei das war 12 4 12 uhr 11 waren erste
kräfte der polizei vor ort
der tod der person hat sich dann das ist
die zu tode gekommene frau nach
überprüfung bestätigt um 12 uhr 11 war
der täter nicht mehr vor ort
12 4 eingang hier der notruf 12 uhr 11
war polizei am tatort
wir können dann weiter rekonstruieren
auch das was ich ihn eben erzählt habe
anhand der helmkamera des täters ich
habe mir heute morgen auch in der lage
den gesamten film bedient entscheidenden
punkten angeguckt
nicht schön aber man kann anhand der
zeit auch das wiederum belegen was hier
an den notrufen eingegangen ist die
rekonstruktion an habt helmkamera des
täters ist nachdem er in der synagoge
oder vor der synagoge eingetroffen war
das nach zweieinhalb minuten der schuss
auf die frau fiel also nachdem
eingetroffen war nach zweieinhalb
minuten der tödliche schuss und abfahrt
des täters von der synagoge nach sieben
minuten er war sieben minuten von 12 uhr
irgendwann praktisch dann in der
synagoge
er ist dann weitergefahren in die ludwig
wucherer straße zum turner imbiss und
hat diesen immer rekonstruiert an der
echtzeit realtime aufzeichnung der
helmkamera nach einer minute dreißig das
heißt da waren elf minuten sei der lage
vergangen da war ahmet öner
nach circa 45 minuten sekunden seit
ankunft haben döner imbiss wirft er
einen sprengsatz in den döner imbiss und
wie schießt personen und der täter
verbleibt sechs minuten haben einen
eigenen ort des döner imbisses und wir
haben dann leider den tod einer weiteren
person in dieser ludwig wucherer straße
im den döner imbiss zu verzeichnen
der täter steigt dann in sein fahrzeug
dort ist dann die polizei wiederum
anwesend versucht ihn an der weiterfahrt
und flucht zu hindern es kommt zu einem
schusswechsel zwischen täter und polizei
der täter wird am hals verletzt
polizeibeamte bleiben unverletzt
funkstreifenwagen beschädigt also
funkstreifenwagen ist bei dem
schusswechsel erschossen worden
der täter flieht im anschluss vom tatort
wird verfolgt gerät dann kurz außer
sicht- und flieht noch mit dem
silberfarbenen pkw vw
dann geht es weiter im tatort kreis
ortslage widdersdorf 13 uhr gibt es eine
meldung dass täter auf anwohner innkreis
ortslage wiesdorf schießt zwei verletzte
auch dies ist eine überprüfung vor ort
bestätigt worden 13 uhr 25 feststellung
des zurückgelassenen ersten
fluchtfahrzeuges in der ortslage keine
annäherung an dieses fahrzeug möglich
wegen des verdachtes von sprengstoff im
fahrzeug dann aufnahme des
fluchtfahrzeuges durch unsere kräfte es
war ein geraubtes taxi dort vor ort in
dem der täter befand richtung münchen
und um 13 uhr 35 verunfallt der täter
auf der b 91 in werschen verlässt das
fahrzeug durch eingesetzte kräfte
unmittelbar festgenommen das heißt nach
eintritt der lage nach ungefähr
anderthalb stunden ist durch zugriff ist
gelungen im täter festzunehmen
nach der festnahme wurde eine verletzung
am hals des täters festgestellt wie aus
der von ihr vorgetragenen verletzung aus
dem schusswechsel resultiert der sich da
sagte er wir vom dünnen fliehen wollte
ergeben hatte wir haben dann eine webcam
festgestellt die wurde sichergestellt
anhand der web kennen die wir
ausgewertet haben kann man das gesamte
tatgeschehen vom anfang bis zum ende
nachvollziehen auch von den von ihr
vorgetragenen zeiten
insgesamt gab es 25 parallel meldung
durch eingehende anrufe die 23 ereignis
orte betrafen das ist in solchen lagen
kunst bekannt so stellt es sich
jedenfalls aus unserer sicht auch
unterlegt durch die durch die täter
aufgezeichneten aufnahmen nach soweit
zum tatablauf und das sollten wir erst
mal gewesen sein
meine damen und herren gestern jom
kippur der höchste jüdische feiertag an
einem solchen tag an ihrem tipp
unabhängig vom geschehen ist in hallen
ist nicht unbedingt zum feiern zumute
ist ist ein 24 stündiger fastentag der
fast ausschließlich mit gebet und der
synagoge begangen wird also
üblicherweise von am tag selber der tag
beginnt die haben abend am folgetag also
in diesem falle dann gestern von
üblicherweise 9 wo ich weiß 1930 bis zum
sonnenuntergang abends es gibt den
begriff der so genannten drei tage juden
das sind die juden die nur am jüdischen
neujahrsfest und eben an die figur in
die synagoge gehen ich will damit zum
ausdruck bringen
der täter hat sich sehr bewusst diesen
tag herausgesucht wenn denn es war ihm
offensichtlich bekannt dass es der tag
ist mit dem sicherlich stärksten
personen zahlt mäßig synagogen besuch
den er hier ganz konkret ins auge
genommen hat zwei todesopfer sind zu
beklagen das mitgefühl gilt angehörigen
die genesungswünsche den verletzten
und doch muss vom glück gesprochen
werden von einem großen glück dass es
dem täter nicht gelang in die synagoge
einzudringen
denn das hätte nicht zwei todesopfer
bedeutet sondern ein massaker
unbeschreiblichen ausmaßes wie wir es in
deutschland überhaupt noch nicht erlebt
haben und ich auch nie erleben möchte
also wir hätten davon müssen wir
ausgehen etwa 60 todesopfer zu beklagen
gehabt wer die synagoge in halle kennt
allein vom räumlichen dort sehr viele
menschen in kurzer zeit zu ermorden wäre
mit der ausstattung des täters leider
muss man sagen ein leichtes gewesen
meine kritik die ich auch gestern
geäußert habe war ist dass die synagoge
zwar einen offensichtlich ganz guten
bautechnischen schutz hatte der täter
hat es nicht geschafft die tür durch
schusswaffengebrauch zu öffnen
das habe nicht wie ich es von den
meisten jüdischen gemeinden in
deutschland kenne eigentlich meiner
eigenen in würzburg wer an diesmal jom
kippur aber auch sonst einen jüdischen
feiertagen während gebetszeiten eine
funkstreife vor ort war eine funkstreife
kann nicht alles verhindern nicht dass
sie mich verstehen aber eine funkstreife
hätte in dieser situation den täter und
vielleicht von vornherein abgeschreckt
auf jeden fall unschädlich machen können
und ich bin davon überzeugt zum zweiten
tatort dem döner imbiss wäre es erst gar
nicht gekommen
jetzt hilft es aber allen und keine mehr
was wenn wir jetzt zurückschauen und
sagen du du tun das war falsch und das
war fahrlässig oder nicht fall ist es
geht darum nach vorne zu schauen
die jüdische gemeinschaft in deutschland
ist durch diesen vorfall in halle weit
über halle hinaus quer durchs
bundesgebiet in erheblichem maße
verunsichert und es ist mir auch wichtig
zu wurde wir sagen was anders und wir
hatten vorher ein gespräch und in diesem
gespräch habe ich die zusicherung des
ministerpräsidenten des innenministers
des landes sachsen anhalt bekommen dass
ab sofort und zwar nicht nur jetzt am
wochenende und am nächste woche
anstehenden laubhüttenfest sondern
nachhaltig also konsequenz ein
polizeischutz für die jüdischen
einrichtungen hier in halle in deshalb
und in magdeburg erfolgen wird das ist
wichtig um auch den menschen die zum
gottesdienst kommen wollen die
sicherheit und das vertrauen zu geben
dass sie gefahrlos in ein jüdisches
gotteshaus gehen können
und ich danke dem bundesinnenminister
der zum ausdruck gebracht hat das
dieses anliegen auch in der nächsten
bundesinnenminister konferenz wo die
innenminister aller bundesländer da sind
noch mal sehr eindeutig darlegen und
fordern wird bundesinnenminister war
nicht nur minister peer war lange zeit
auch ministerpräsident in bayern und die
schutzmaßnahmen wie wir sie in bayern
kennen sind glaube ich die die man
tatsächlich hier erwarten muss die nicht
übertrieben sind die aber leider
notwendig sind wenn es mir auch viel
wohler wäre wenn wir sie nicht nötig
hätten insoweit und ich gehe davon aus
dass aus den vorfällen des gestrigen
tages generell gelernt wurde in
polizeibehörden in sicherheitsbehörden
und deshalb auch der klare hinweis dass
jüdische menschen in deutschland sicher
sein können an diesem morgen abend
beginnen den schabbat am brückenfest
nächste woche montag und dienstag ohne
angst und furcht die synagogen in
deutschland aufsuchen zu können
eine letzte bemerkung noch die nicht
direkt die innenminister betrifft und
trotzdem für mich wichtig ist ich habe
das gefühl dass das was dann das ist das
nach tat das nächste was von seiten der
justiz getan wird oder getan werden kann
ich bin kein jurist nicht ausreichend
ist im klartext dass bei antisemitischen
straftaten häufig urteile ergehen die in
ihrer milde für mich nicht
nachvollziehbar sind oder konkret der
vorfall am freitag in berlin als ein
attentäter mit einem messer bewaffnete
polizeibeamten zu gehen dann gefasst
werden konnte und deshalb kein
haftbefehl von der staatsanwaltschaft
die polizei hatte absolut korrekt
gehandelt von der staatsanwaltschaft
erlassen wurde
weil ein messerangriff auf einen
bewaffneten polizeibeamten ein nicht
geeigneter versuch sei also das muss ich
ehrlich sagen erschließt sich mir als
mediziner bin kein jurist erschließt
sich mir oder vielleicht mit logischem
menschenverstand nicht ich denke hier
ist die justiz gefordert
auch in ihrer gesetzgebung sehr klare
linien zu schaffen der antisemitismus
beauftragte der klein hat vor einigen
wochen hier klarere gesetzliche und auch
schärfere gesetzliche regelungen
gefordert ich unterstütze ihn
diesbezüglich vollumfänglich vielen dank
meine damen und herren dieses brutale
verbrechen gestern ist eine schande für
unser ganzes land in unserer geschichte
darf so etwas in deutschland eigentlich
nicht passieren wir müssen leider der
wahrheit ins gesicht blicken und die
wahrheit lautet schon seit längerem die
bedrohungslage durch antisemitismus dass
rechtsextremismus durch
rechtsterrorismus in deutschland ist
sehr hoch die gewaltbereitschaft in
diesem bereich ist sehr hoch die waffen
affinität ist sehr hoch und ich habe das
in den letzten monaten insbesondere vor
der bundespressekonferenz immer wieder
betont dass dies neben dem
islamistischen terrorismus
die zentrale herausforderung für unser
land ist
darauf muss reagiert werden und zwar
noch stärker als in der vergangenheit
natürlich müssen synagogen und jüdische
einrichtungen hier besser geschützt
werden
da denke ich auch für die zusage heute
der ministerpräsident und herr minister
dass dies ab sofort geschieht
ich möchte noch hinzufügen dass wir in
diesem gespräch ihrer vereinbart haben
dies soll nachhaltig sein
das heißt übersetzt jetzt nicht nur als
reaktion sondern eben dauerhaft und es
muss so gestaltet werden dass
sicherheitsmaßnahmen für andere bereiche
deshalb nicht zurückgefahren werden
das heißt es muss zusätzlich geschehen
denn man könnte es nicht vertreten wenn
die verstärkung der sicherheit in einem
bereich zu lasten der sicherheit in
einem anderen bereich gibt das war der
ausdrückliche wunsch der schuss der von
euch weil sonst kriegen wir eine nicht
ganz einfache diskussion in der
bevölkerung
ich habe morgen bereits eingeladen alle
sicherheitsbehörden einschließlich der
beiden koalitionsfraktionen dass wir
auch noch einmal eine bestandsaufnahme
machen uns gemeinsam überlegen wo können
wir noch und müssen wir
sicherheitsmaßnahmen auch vom bund her
verstärken sei es durch personal sei es
durch sächliche ausstattung sei es durch
gesetzliche grundlagen und nächsten
freitag die wie holger stahlknecht
werden wir uns ja hier treffen in berlin
der vorsitzende der
innenministerkonferenz hat heute in
abstimmung mit wir dazu eingeladen das
auch die innenminister aller
bundesländer gemeinsam mit dem
bundesinnenminister
diese diese herausforderung gesprächen
und überlegen was können wir noch
zusätzlich tun das sind wir es schuldig
das sind wir auch den opfern schuldig
nachdem ich heute erfahren habe dass
auch tage später diese
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz in bayern
sein wird kann ich mir vorstellen dass
wir auch einige punkte zusammen stehen
wie nur auf der ebene der
ministerpräsidenten entschieden werden
kann
wir müssen vor allem angehen
die hasper holen und das was im internet
abläuft
das ist immer ein vorlauf für
tatsächlich gewalt und ich muss ihnen
sagen ich persönlich habe ich noch nie
erlebt in meiner langen politischen
tätigkeit eines halben jahrhunderts das
nach einem mord an herrn lübke über eine
so lange zeit unterbrochen und mit
erheblicher zahl ein opfer verhöhnt wird
und der täter probiert wird gelobt ich
habe es damals als sittenverfall in
unserem lande bezeichnet aber nachdem
worte nicht immer reichen
das wissen wir bin ich gemeinsam mit der
bundesjustizministerin schon seit
einigen tagen dabei wie wir
strafrechtlich relevante äußerungen im
internet verfolgen
vor allem dann wenn sie einen
straftatbestand darstellen
einschließlich der preisgabe der ip
nummer und das ist dann ein lackmustest
für uns alle
ob wir als rechtsstaat in der lage sind
uns mit bis zu wehren
gegen die gegner des rechtsstaats das
sind ja systemgegner die hier unterwegs
sind
oder ob wir in der lage sind die
freiheitliche demokratische grundordnung
zu verteidigen da geht es nicht um die
einschränkung von bürgerrechten sondern
um die verkennt bekämpfung von
verbrechen und auf diesem weg wird uns
auch niemand aufhalten
und er muss wesentlich konsequenter
abgegangen werden
wir werden was den bund betrifft das ist
jetzt nicht ganz neu muss aber hier
nochmal erwähnt werden die
sicherheitsbehörden massiv aufstocken
wir werden beim bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz und beim
bundeskriminalamt mit einigen hundert
personen zusätzlich auch hier gilt man
kann mit personen aus der bekämpfung des
islamistischen terrors abziehen um sie
für die bekämpfung des rechtsstaates
einzusetzen
wir brauchen beides wir brauchen also
einige hundert zusätzliche planstellen
ich denke die werden wir in den
haushaltsberatungen die gerade laufen
und im november abgeschlossen werden
bekommen und wir wollen bei der
bekämpfung des rechtsextremismus der
hass parolen und des terrorismus
die gleichen organisationseinheiten
errichten wie bei der bekämpfung des
islamistischen terrors
das ist ganz ganz wichtig denn alleine
die überwachung des internets die
verfolgung von straftaten im internet
ist eine sehr sehr personalintensive
sache da kann man einiges automatisieren
aber meine damen und herren am
wirksamsten bleibt immer noch der mensch
bei der bekämpfung der kriminalität des
verbrechens des terrors und ich begrüße
auch sehr das freut mich lieber herr
ministerpräsident
wir müssen auch erreichen dass die
demokraten aufstehen deshalb ist es
heute gut was ihr am marktplatz macht
und auch hier müssen wir dazu beitragen
dass dies nicht für den augenblick
maßnahmen sind sondern dass dies eine
dauerhafte relegiert
die bundesrepublik deutschland hat einen
schule gegenüber der ganzen welt
abgegeben
nie wieder und gerade in solchen stunden
fühlen wir uns diesen schuhen tief
verpflichtet
und er wusste ich möchte ihnen sagen
diese bundesregierung wird alles tun
dass die juden in unserem lande ohne
bedrohung ohne angst leben können sie
haben mich erlebt in bayern und weiß
ganz wichtig dass wir all den dingen die
wir heute besprechen die ihr bespricht
die wir weiter besprechen
das diesen gesprächen und worten auch
dann die ganz praktischen taten folgen
das schafft vertrauen und wird auch
diesem schwurgericht nie wieder
herzlichen dank jetzt gefundenen
blättern
ja das war ein sehr nachdenklicher ein
sehr nachdrücklicher bundesinnenminister
seehofer der nach dem attentat in habe
deutliche worte gefunden hat er gesagt
hat es ist eine schande für unser land
dass was passiert es angesichts der
geschichte deutschlands und er hat auch
deutlich gesagt hassparolen gegen die
muss man vorgehen denn es ist immer ein
vorläufer für tatsächliche gewalt und es
war sehr deutlich an den präsidenten des
zentralrats der juden in deutschland
gerichtet als er gesagt hat der schwur
der soll aufrechterhalten werden nie
wieder verfolgung von juden in
deutschland das hat andere wichtige
aussagen gegeben
der ministerpräsident von sachsen anhalt
hat gesagt es soll einheitliche
standards geben denn er spielt darauf an
dass polizeistreifen beispielsweise in
berlin vor synagogen immer gab in
sachsen anhalt war das nicht der fall
und deshalb setzt er sich ein auf der
innenministerkonferenz dafür zu sorgen
dass es einheitliche standards in allen
bundesländern in dieser richtung gibt
und der präsident des zentralrats der
juden in deutschland hat deutlich
gemacht dass er einerseits kritik übt
dass es keine funkstreife vor der
synagoge in halle gegeben hat aber er
sagte auch dass es nicht nach hinten
blicken sondern nach vorne und er
begrüßt es dass er die zusage sowohl vom
ministerpräsidenten sachsen-anhalts als
auch des innenministers bekommen hat
dass es in zukunft konsequenzen
konsequenten schutz für synagogen in
sachsen anhalt geben wird gleichzeitig
verlangte er klarere gesetzliche
regelungen so ungefähr zusammengefasst
das wichtigste dieser pressekonferenz in
halle
das war das heute spezial zum attentat
in halle mit vielen neuen informationen
auf verschiedenen pressekonferenzen
erhalten sie auf dem weiterhin neuesten
stand auf heute.de jetzt geht's weiter
mit heute in europa
[Musik]
maybrit illner mit dem thema anschlag in
halle tödlicher judenhass in deutschland
unter anderem mit reiner haseloff
ministerpräsident marina weisband
autorin und terrorismusexperte elmar p
wissen maybrit illner 22 15 im zdf
[Musik]